Sie wollten noch einmal an den Ort in Hanau,
wo vor einem Jahr Gökhan Gültekin
erschossen wurde,
ihr Bruder und Onkel.
Da, wo diese zwei Steckdosen sind,
lag mein Bruder.
Die ganzen Blaulichter,
die ganzen Menschen.
Das haben wir erst mal am Anfang nicht
realisiert, was eigentlich passiert ist.
Kurz nach dem Attentat am 19.02.2020 eilen
Çetin und Mert Gültekin an den Tatort.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hat der Täter Tobias R.
bereits gezielt neun Menschen getötet –
alle mit Migrationsgeschichte.
Dann erschießt er seine
Mutter und sich selbst.
Der 37-jährige Gökhan war eines der Opfer.
Seit dieser Nacht ist für die
Gültekins nichts mehr, wie es war:
Die Mutter kommt ohne
Medikamente nicht mehr zurecht.
Der Vater erliegt kurz nach dem Tod
seines Sohnes seinem Krebsleiden.
Bruder Çetin und sein Sohn sind traumatisiert
und können nicht mehr arbeiten.
Der Gökhan war das Fundament.
Und seitdem unser Fundament
nicht mehr da ist,
sind wir nur noch am Wackeln.
Jede Wand wackelt momentan.
Und seit einem Jahr gibt [es] keine
einzige Nacht, wo ich sage:
Ich bin [habe] mal durchgeschlafen.
Du kannst nicht mehr schlafen,
weil gerade nachts, wenn [es] dunkel ist,
wenn du deinen Kopf an
den [das] Kissen lehnst,
kommen dann die Fragen,
die dich richtig fressen.
Die Familie zieht um, weil die alte
Wohnung zu nah am Tatort ist
und sie es dort nicht mehr aushalten.
Vater und Sohn teilen sich
seitdem ein Zimmer.
Ich komm damit nicht klar.
In der alten Wohnung,
als ich nach links umgedreht bin,
habe ich das Bett gesehen, war komplett leer.
Und deswegen ist es sehr wichtig, dass wir
zusammen in einem Zimmer schlafen.
Zur Trauer mischt sich aber
auch immer mehr Wut.
Seit einem Jahr schreien wir, schreien wir,
schreien wir
und bis heute kein einziges
Erfolgserlebnis, dass wir sagen:
Weißt du, hier, das haben wir
wenigstens geschafft.
Nur ins Leere, nur ins Leere, nur ins Leere.
Und diese Politiker tun uns jedes Mal
angucken, uns anlächeln.
Den Angehörigen reicht das nicht.
Sie haben zusammen mit Unterstützern die
„Initiative 19. Februar“ gegründet und fordern,
dass die Behörden Verantwortung
übernehmen.
Warum hatte der Täter einen Waffenschein,
obwohl er psychisch krank war?
Oder warum war der Notruf
der Polizei in der Tatnacht
anscheinend nicht ausreichend besetzt?
Weder das Hessische Innenministerium
noch die Hanauer Polizei
sind zu einem Interview bereit.
Doch die Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft
äußert sich.
Verantwortung für
die Polizei in dem Sinne,
dass sie an der einen oder anderen Stelle
das und das hätte tun können,
und dann wäre es verhindert worden,
die sehe ich in der Tat nicht.
Insofern ist es sehr wohlfeil,
hinterher zu sagen,
was die Polizei alles hätte
vorher wissen müssen.
Çetin Gültekin fühlt sich
in Deutschland nicht mehr sicher.
Der türkischstämmige Hanauer hat Angst,
wenn er nachts unterwegs ist –
oder wenn sein Sohn zu
spät nach Hause kommt.
Denn rechtsextreme Attentate
nehmen immer weiter zu.
Davor warnen auch
Expertinnen und Experten.
Wir brauchen sehr deutlich eine starke
Prävention gegen Rechtsextremismus,
das heißt, die Behandlung des
Themas muss früh anfangen,
wir müssen vorbeugend handeln.
Wir müssen sozusagen
vor die Lage kommen,
nicht erst dann uns immer etwas
ausdenken, was wir tun können,
bei der Strafverfolgung, bei der
Sicherheitsarbeit, nachdem etwas passiert ist.
Rechtsextreme Einstellungen sind vorher da
und sie motivieren Menschen dann,
sich Organisationen anzuschließen.
Gültekin fordert, solidarisch zu sein –
und wachsamer.
Er hat mir mein Leben weggenommen.
Er hat mir alles, mein …
alles weggenommen.
Wem hab ich was getan?
Und deswegen, seit einem Jahr,
kämpfen wir mit Familien
für Gerechtigkeit und Aufklärung.